مين ده بص حيث عقد المنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي قالها الامين العام للامم المتحده
معطيات ومؤشرات العام الحالي تبدو كسابقه
لتكون المهمه الاساسيه التي اجمع عليها
الكل في 2003
هي تجنب السيناريو الاسود وطبعا لكل ازمه
اقتصاديه اسباب لكن اساس الوضع الحالي هو
التضخم او ما تعرفوا بطريقه الفقراء ظاهره
اددت الى اكبر تجديدا للسياسه النقديه منذ
عقود وقت لازم العالم لسنوات
وعادلته التضخم غير المسبوقه اثرت علينا
تاكله القدره الشرائيه للمستهين سبعون
مليون شخص نزلوا تحت خط الفقر بسبب التضخم
ووقود هذا التضخم كان اموال الدعم الذي
خصصته الحكومات للحد من اثار جائه كورونا
تحولت من نعمه الى نقمه
بفهم الاسباب نعود الى نهايه اجراءات
الاغلاق بعد انحصار الجائحه رغم متحورها
وقتها عاد الاقتصاد الى النمو اسرع من
المتوقع المصانع التي جمدت الانتاج لم
تواكب ارتفاع الطلب الاقتصاد الصيني بدوره
فاثر بالسياسه صفر كوفد التي الغيت قبل
اسابيع الطلب لم تقابله وفره في الانتاج
اللي تبدا الاسعار في الارتفاع وهنا خرج
التضخم عن السيطره ليستمر في الارتفاع
بسبب الحرب الاخرانيه